[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the future ex-president of
the United States of America is unstable
that is not my opinion that it's not the
media's opinion that is America's
opinion in a new poll a poll not by fake
news but by Fox News question 24 Fox
News Anderson Robbins Shaw poll
registered voters August 27 to 29 how
well do you think each of the following
words or phrases describe Donald Trump
and there it is coming up with the third
highest overall score bind
says what he thinks and bully quote
unstable unquote 33 percent of
respondents say the word unstable
describes him extremely well 11 percent
of respondents say the word unstable
describes him very well 16 percent of
respondents say the word unstable
describes him somewhat well that's 60
percent of respondents agreeing he's on
stable and this is not the result of
some sort of either/or choice by the way
they were given a list of terms like
presidential which 56 percent of the
same people told Fox News does not
describe Trump at all but six out of ten
Americans reading that list think he's
unstable six out of ten in a poll that
this year has skewed about five points
in Trump's favor that had his approval
at 41 when Gallup had it at 35 um stable
so why isn't this point being debated
publicly every day why is there no cable
news show called is the president
unstable when a president was being
impeached after an extramarital affair
they made me do a show called White
House in crisis every night two hundred
and twenty eight consecutive programs I
still have the scars all the network's
loaded up on supposed legal experts most
of whom had never met the president nor
his accusers nor the others involved nor
his political opponents but who talked
about his legal case 24 hours a day
right now Trump's policies on North
Korea and China are being debated
constantly by people who know no
in either country his wall is being
debated by people who know nothing of
immigration or the plight of the
dreamers or the deported his actions
against people of color and women in
LGBTQ and every other group are being
debated on television by a panel usually
made up of only straight white guys 6
out of 10 Americans believe Trump is
unstable and 44% said he was very or
extremely unstable in a box poll and
this does not get debated and this does
not get its own show and this does not
get its own 24-hour political debate
network bob Corker the Republican
senator from Tennessee said Trump quote
has not yet been able to demonstrate the
stability which is a milquetoast way of
calling him unstable Duncan Hunter the
Republican congressman and Trump's
supporter from San Diego reportedly told
the young Republicans their quote he's
just like he is on TV he's an [ __ ]
but he's our [ __ ] unquote last Friday
we weren't Trump was weird enough or odd
and offered maybe the phrase I want here
is unstable enough to have reportedly
drafted a letter firing James Comey
because Comey would not clear Trump on
Russia and thus he left literally an
impeachable obstruction of justice paper
trail in the last week Trump himself
made sure he attacked the media while
pretending to comfort those affected by
hurricane Harvey and then he made sure
he attacked Hillary Clinton right after
he got back to the White House from
pretending to comfort those affected by
hurricane Harvey and he had already
explained he had pardoned Joe Arpaio
during hurricane Harvey because he
thought the TV ratings would be higher
then he reportedly demoted one of his
four longest-serving political aides
because he blamed the man for the size
of his crowd at his rally in Phoenix you
saw his statements about charlottesville
in those he displayed the stability of a
Kardashian family ex-husband and in the
last two years you've seen what a
hundred examples of him being not right
a thousand more not right
unstable unhinged unsound unglued
unbalanced unbelievable odd off strange
weird nonsensical erratic foolish
idiotic
implausible raving haywire bizarre
absurd ludicrous half-baked cockamamie
preposterous deranged demented delirious
delusional lunatic screwy touched
maniacal monomaniacal cracked
hallucinatory out to lunch out of his
mind
paranoiac narcissistic sociopathic
psychopathic crazy and we don't talk
about it we don't talk about it for two
primary reasons with the best of
intentions in 1973 the American
Psychiatric Association established in
its principles of medical ethics section
number seven which reads on occasion
psychiatrist are asked for an opinion
about an individual who is in the light
of public attention or who has disclosed
information about himself herself
through public media in such
circumstances a psychiatrist may share
with the public his or her expertise
about psychiatric issues in general
however it is unethical for a
psychiatrist to offer a professional
opinion
unless he or she has conducted an
examination and has been granted proper
authorization for such a statement that
is the Goldwater rule instituted because
after the Republican presidential
nominee of 1964 Barry Goldwater
postulated some scenarios in which he
would use nuclear weapons two years
after the Cuban Missile Crisis a lot of
psychiatrist came out and said he was
nuts for forty four years this has been
considered a benchmark of professional
restraint and medical dignity when in
fact it was pretty much pure cya
entirely predicated on Goldwater having
sued the publisher of a magazine called
fact accurate put out this issue
claiming 1189 different psychiatrists
had said Goldwater was quote
psychologically unfit to be President
Goldwater sued for libel
he got $75,000 which was a great deal of
money then and the psychiatric
association suddenly had a new principle
which was at best part medical ethics in
part don't get your ass sued physical
health you can speculate about the
physical health of a public figure of a
president or would-be president
permanently
during the campaign last year Trump said
Clinton lacked mental and physical
stamina and Rudy Guiliani said you could
tell she was sick just by going online
and Karl Rove along with Fox and Friends
declared that her glasses were the kind
worn only by people who had had
traumatic brain injury and Sean Hannity
suggested she had a stroke and said she
had a seizure and post concussion
syndrome and demanded her medical
records and Alex Jones site claimed she
had Parkinson's disease and was dying a
blood clots in the Daily Caller said she
had a urinary tract infection and john
bolton said she was faking it but mental
health even if six out of ten americans
in a fox poll think he is unstable and
there is still no NBC Nightly how
unstable is he news it's not being
debated and it's not being debated
because of one of the great logical
fallacies of our time one that has been
whispered and screamed at me for months
this is simply as follows if you're not
fully trained in psychology if you don't
have a medical degree how dare you give
an opinion that the president is crazy
it is an argument that mostly goes
unanswered and news presidents and show
producers and commentators run from this
argument in terror all because they
never stopped to realize that if it is
inappropriate for non psychiatrists to
publicly express the opinion that the
president is psychologically unstable
then it is necessarily an absolutely
just as inappropriate for non
psychiatrists to publicly express the
opinion that the president is not
psychologically unstable even if I've
consulted dozen of professionals and
applied some of the very tests that they
use I can't say he's nuts but anybody
else can say no of course he's not nuts
to hell with that
the American people have spoken how well
do you think the word unstable describes
Donald Trump 33% unstable describes him
extremely well
11% unstable describes him very well 16%
unstable describes him somewhat well 60%
unstable describes him well America has
spoken he's unstable it is time for the
American political media to do the same
resist remove peace oh and not
completely coincidentally the book of
these commentaries Trump is effing crazy
this book of mine comes out October 17th
you can pre-order it now or not or just
wait for the premiere of NBC nightly how
unstable is he news or something